>>> SO, THERE'S BEEN A LOT SAID
ABOUT TWITTER'S NEW OWNER,
BILLIONAIRE ELON MUSK,
ESPECIALLY AFTER MR. MUSK
TWEETED OUT A LINK TO A DERANGED
RIGHT WING WEBSITE TO FURTHER
THE SMEARING OF PAUL PELOSI, THE
SPEAKER'S HUSBAND, WHOM A
DERANGED MAN ATTACKED WITH A
HAMMER.
THE WEBSITE REPORTED IN 2016
THAT HILLARY CLINTON HAD DIED
AND THAT A BODY DOUBLE WOULD
DEBATE DONALD TRUMP.
THE HOST OF JIMMY KIMMEL LIVE ON
ABC TWEETED, AFTER MUSK DID
THIS, IT HAS BEEN INTERESTING
OVER THE YEARS TO WATCH YOU
BLOSSOM FROM THE ELECTRIC CAR
GUY INTO A FULLY FORMED PIECE OF
SHIT.
AND JIMMY KIMMEL JOINS ME NOW.
JIMMY, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
INTEREST TWEET, STRONG WORDS.
AND IT DOES PLAY RIGHT INTO THIS
NATIONAL CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN
HAVING ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
HOW DO YOU SEE THOSE ISSUES,
GIVEN FREE SPEECH ON ONE HAND
AND YET THE DANGEROUS SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION AND HATEFUL
RHETORIC THAT'S INCITING SOME OF
THESE ATTACKS ON THE OTHER?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, JAKE, I
LOVE HEARING YOU CURSE.
IT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS.
I KNOW IT ONLY HAPPENS ONCE
EVERY -- I ONLY QUOTE PEOPLE
CURSING.
I NEVER CURSE ON MY OWN.
IT'S ONLY WITHIN QUOTATIONS.
THE TRUMP ERA GAVE ME A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT, BY THE
WAY.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
NO, I LIKE IT.
IT'S LIKE CNN AFTER DARK YOU
KNOW.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY WHEN I
HAVE THE VOICE OF DECENCY WE'VE
GOT A PROBLEM BECAUSE THE IDEA
THAT THIS OLD MAN, AN
82-YEAR-OLD MAN, HAS BEEN
ATTACKED IN HIS BED IN HIS HOME
BY A PERSON WHO OBVIOUSLY HAS
SOME PROBLEMS AND OUR FIRST
REACTION ISN'T, OH, MY GOODNESS.
EVEN IF THEY'RE LYING, EVEN IF
THEY'RE PRETENDING TO HAVE
CONCERN, HOW CAN THE REACTION
POSSIBLY BE -- HOW CAN WE MOVE
SO QUICKLY TO SMEARING THESE
PEOPLE TO TRY TO CREATE SOME --
YOU KNOW BY THE WAY NOW THAT THE
POLICE REPORT IS OUT, I HAVEN'T
EXACTLY SEEN ELON MUSK OR DONALD
TRUMP OR DONNY JR. CORRECTING
THEM AND SAYING, OH, MY
GOODNESS, NOW THAT WE READ THE
FACTS OF THIS STORY, CERTAINLY
WE FEEL TERRIBLE THAT WE SPREAD
THESE VICIOUS LIES AROUND.
AND WE RETRACT THEM AND
APOLOGIZE TO THE PELOSI FAMILY.
NO, YOU'LL NEVER SEE THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
EVERYBODY IS A TARGET ALL THE
TIME NOW.
>> AND IT'S NOT JUST THE SMEARS
THAT THEY PUT OUT ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI, THESE DERANGED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
A LOT OF THESE FOLKS, RIGHT WING
MAGA FOLKS, TRIED TO MAKE JOKES
AT PAUL PELOSI'S EXPENSE, ONE
THAT PAUL PELOSI HAD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS ATTACKER.
YOU ARE NOT AFRAID OF TAKING
RISKS IN COMEDY.
WHERE'S THE LINE?
I PERSONALLY FOUND THOSE JOKES
BY JOHN JR. AND OTHERS JUST
HORRIBLE AND NOT EVEN REMOTELY
FUNNY.
>> THE LINE IS WHEN DON JR.
TELLS A JOKE.
WHEN DON JR. TELLS A JOKE, THE
LINE HAS BEEN CROSSED BECAUSE
HE'S NOT A FUNNY PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
DON'S LIFE, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE AN
AWFUL LOT OF PROJECTION GOING ON
THERE TO ME.
AND I JUST -- YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW.
THE LINE, I GUESS, IS WHEN AN
82-YEAR-OLD MAN GETS HIT IN THE
HEAD WITH A HAMMER.
>> THAT'S A GOOD LINE.
THIS ALSO COMES AT THE SAME TIME
THAT KANYE WEST, NOW KNOWN AS
YE, WHO I KNOW YOU'VE
INTERVIEWED IN THE PAST, HE SAID
HE COULD TELL YOU ANYTHING HE
WANTED ANTI-SEMITIC AND ADIDAS
COULDN'T DROP HIM.
ADIDAS DID DROP HIM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, KYRIE IRVING
IS OUT THERE FLIRTING WITH
ANTI-SEMITISM, CONTINUES TO
PLAY.
HOW DO YOU THINK CELEBRITIES WHO
SPEW BIGOTRY, PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PLATFORMS, SHOULD BE TREATED?
WHAT KIND OF CONSEQUENCES SHOULD
THERE BE?
>> I JUST, YOU KNOW, IT MAKES ME
WONDER WHO TOLD THEM THIS STUFF?
HOW DID THIS GET INTO THEIR
HEADS IN THE FIRST PLACE?
I MEAN, ON ONE SIDE, YOU COULD
SAY, MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T TAKE
ANYTHING THAT THESE GUYS SAY
SERIOUSLY.
I MEAN, IF YOU SEE SOMEONE
RANTING AND RAVING ON THE STREET
CORNER, YOU'RE NOT NECESSARILY
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR WORDS.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, THESE ARE
VERY SPECIFIC -- I MEAN, THEY'VE
SINGLED OUT RELIGIOUS GROUP AND
DECIDED THAT ALL THE EVILS OF
THE WORLD ARE SOMEHOW ATTACHED
TO THAT GROUP.
IT'S BEYOND OFFENSIVE.
IT'S ACTUALLY NONSENSICAL.
AND I DON'T THINK KANYE WEST IS
A STUPID PERSON, AND I DON'T
THINK KYRIE IRVING -- I MEAN,
KYRIE IRVING DOES THINK THE
WORLD IS FLAT, SO THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
>> HE WENT TO DUKE THOUGH.
HE'S PRETTY SMART.
>> WELL, I MEAN, HE WENT TO
DUKE.
WOULD HE HAVE GONE TO DUKE HAD
HE NOT BEEN A GREAT BASKETBALL
PLAYER?
THAT'S FOR THE ADMISSIONS PEOPLE
AT DUKE.
BUT MIGHT BE TIME TO TAKE HIS
DIPLOMA BACK.
>> SO, YET AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS, YOU
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
PRIVATELY, THIS ERA OF SO-CALLED
CANCEL CULTURE, WHERE CAREERS
GET RUINED BECAUSE SOMEBODY SAYS
SOMETHING WRONG OR MAKES A
MISTAKE.
OBVIOUSLY IF THEY COMMIT A
CRIME, THAT'S A SEPARATE THING.
BUT I THINK -- AND I THINK YOU
WOULD AGREE WITH ME -- THAT
THERE DOES NEED TO BE ROOM FOR
PEOPLE TO APOLOGIZE, AS LONG AS
IT'S A SINCERE APOLOGY.
I SAW THIS REPORT TODAY ABOUT
THIS YOUNG SPORTS REPORTER IN
CASEY FUNDERBURG.
SHE OBJECTED TO SOME RACISM SHE
SAW AS A SPORTS REPORTER AND
THEN PAST RACIST TWEETS SHE HAD
MADE WHEN SHE WAS A TEENAGER AND
SHE WAS FIRED TO.
ME, THAT SEEMS LIKE, LOOK, IF
SHE'S -- I DON'T HAVE A --
PEOPLE -- THERE NEEDS TO BE
SPACE FOR PEOPLE TO APOLOGIZE IN
THIS WORLD.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IF THERE ISN'T,
THEN WHERE DO WE GO?
LISTEN, OBVIOUSLY I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED THE IN A -- I'VE SAID A
MILLION STUPID THINGS, AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE WOULD
DECIDE WHETHER AN APOLOGY IS
SINCERE.
WHEN AN APOLOGY ISN'T EVEN
OFFERED, THAT'S -- LISTEN, THESE
PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
CHRISTIANS.
I AM A CATHOLIC.
I GREW UP IN THE CHURCH.
WHAT I WAS TAUGHT WAS THAT IF
YOU DO SOMETHING WRONG, YOU ASK
FOR FORGIVENESS AND YOU ARE
FORGIVEN FOR THESE THINGS.
THE IDEA THAT THAT WOULD BE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THAT, THAT
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE ALLEGEDLY
FOLLOWING THE TEACHINGS OF JESUS
WOULD BEHAVE IN THIS WAY, IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL.
AND I DON'T -- I JUST CAN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WORKS FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE, SO MANY AMERICANS.
>> IT'S NOT JUST RELIGIOUS --
IT'S NOT JUST RELIGIOUS PEOPLE
ON THE RIGHT THOUGH, RIGHT?
THERE ARE PROGRESSIVES ON THE
LEFT THAT CAN BE PRETTY TOUGH
ABOUT THIS.
>> NO, YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
JUST AS IF NOT MORE SO.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE'S MORE
OPENNESS TO FORGIVENESS FROM
THAT PARTICULAR SIDE.
BUT WITH THAT SAID, PEOPLE DO
LIKE PILING ON.
THEY LOVE IT.
MAKES THEM FEEL LIKE THEY'RE A
BETTER PERSON.
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT OF THAT
GOING ON.
AND I TELL YOU WHAT, I'VE
NOTICED -- THIS IS JUST MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
I NOTICED THAT IN THE THREE DAYS
THAT ELON MUSK HAS BEEN RUNNING
THIS TWITTER THAT IT HAS GOTTEN
CRAZIER AND NASTIER.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, I'M WALKING IN
AN ALS WALK IN LAS VEGAS ON
SUNDAY ON MY BIRTHDAY, NOVEMBER
13th --
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
>> -- AND I POSTED ABOUT IT --
THANK YOU -- AND I JUST GOT AN
AVALANCHE OF HATE.
HATE.
AND IT'S JUST LIKE, WELL, YOU
CAN'T EVEN -- YOU CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ANYMORE WITHOUT BEING
ATTACKED.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
>> NO.
I AGREE.
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE
APPROACHING.
I HAVE TO SAY, WHATEVER YOU FEEL
ABOUT REPUBLICANS TAKING BACK
THE HOUSE, WHICH SEEMS LIKELY,
PERHAPS AS A COMEDIAN YOU'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT?
MORE PROMINENCE FOR PEOPLE LIKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
SHE BRINGS YOU INFORMATION.
SHE BRINGS YOU FODDER.
>> NO, I DON'T -- I'M NOT THAT
DESPERATE FOR MATERIAL.
I'M REALLY NOT.
I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING ALSO,
I HAVE A BONE TO PICK WITH YOU.
>> UH-OH.
>> WE WATCH YOU IN MY OFFICE
EVERY DAY BEFORE THE SHOW, AND
THEN YOU DECIDE TO ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU DECIDE TO SLIDE INTO
THE NIGHT SLOT.
THIS IS WHEN I'M TAPING THE
SHOW.
IT'S NOT CONVENIENT FOR ME AT
ALL.
SO, I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR THAT
YOU'RE MOVING BACK TO 4:00, AND
I'D LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT YOU DID
IT SPECIFICALLY FOR ME.
>> I DID IT BECAUSE OF MY FAMILY
AND IT WAS ALWAYS JUST A
SHORT-TERM GIG FOR --
>> BUT A LITTLE